Speaker 1: So we talked about should unvaccinated
workers be fired?
And my position there is if the company has
announced you must be vaccinated or you can't
work here, they cannot be empty threats that
if you're saying you're going to fire people,
if they're not vaccinated, you've absolutely
got to do it.
OK, so the next question is when people when
workers say I'll quit.
Do they actually do it and increasingly the
evidence is they do not.
Let's look at a couple articles from Massachusetts
related to Massachusetts state police.
There are reportedly just under twenty two
hundred state troopers right now.
OK, let's call it two hundred.
It's actually twenty one eighty seven.
Dozens of Massachusetts state police troopers
have been resigning, a claim that they are
resigning over the covid vaccine mandate.
Union says this is an article from yesterday
and this article says the State Police Association
of Massachusetts says dozens of troopers have
submitted their resignation papers as a result
of the mandate.
The state is requiring all executive department
employees to show proof of vaccination by
the 17th or risk losing their jobs.
About 20 percent of state police employees
are not vaccinated, according to the union's
attorney, a source told ABC TV on Monday.
Only one state trooper has told human resources
they would resign because of the vaccine mandate.
They also said there are others who spoke
with H.R. to evaluate what their pensions
would be if they chose to retire.
The union released this statement to date,
dozens of troopers have submitted resignation
paperwork, some of whom planned to retire
to to other departments offering alternatives
such as mask wearing and regular testing.
The state police are already critically short
staffed and acknowledged this by the unprecedented
moves which took troopers from specialty units
that investigate homicides.
So you've got a story, which is the union
says dozens have submitted resignation paperwork,
but then only one person has actually said,
I'm resigning to human resources.
Another article from the Boston Globe State
Police Union says dozens of troopers plan
to resign due to vaccine mandate, but police
spokesman says only one definitively has.
So we have to wonder we have to wonder is
what's going on with the union?
The union claiming dozens have submitted resignation.
Does that actually translate to people are
actually really going to quit?
So far, it's one out of two thousand one hundred
and eighty seven Massachusetts state troopers
that have actually communicated this to human
resources.
I'm not saying that the union is lying, but
I'm wondering whether they've collected resignation
letters that many don't actually intend to
give to anybody in human resources as part
of a political statement of sorts.
These are good jobs, you know, but there's
the waiting list.
To become a Massachusetts state trooper is
very, very long.
And these are really good jobs.
Are they really going to quit over a vaccine
requirement in particular when their pensions
may be at risk?
The real headline so far seems to be fewer
than what is it.
One tenth of one percent of troopers have
actually resisted the vaccination requirement.
It's very easy to talk about quitting a well-paying
job with great health care and retirement
benefits over a safe vaccine.
But it's a very different thing to actually
go and to do it.
So my question is, are a lot of these people
just bluffing and they're not really going
to quit?